>> Sandra: FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE THE CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS
THE U.S. IS REPORTEDLY MAKING
PLANS FOR THE POSSIBILITY OF
RUSSIA USING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
PUTIN SAYS HE WOULD USE ALL
AVAILABLE MEANS TO DEFEND HIS
TERRITORY.
DEFENSE SECRETARY LLOYD AUSTIN
THINKS PUTIN MAY ACTUALLY FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH THAT THREAT.
>> THERE ARE NO CHECKS ON
MR. PUTIN.
JUST AS HE MADE THE
IRRESPONSIBLE DECISION TO INVADE
UKRAINE, HE COULD MAKE ANOTHER
DECISION.
I DON'T SEE ANYTHING RIGHT NOW
THAT WOULD LEAD ME TO BELIEVE HE
HAS MADE SUCH A DECISION.
>> Sandra: FORMER CIA DIRECTOR
DAVID PETRAEUS SAYS THAT YOU
MUST BE FORCED TO RESPOND IF
PUTIN GOES NUCLEAR.
>> WE WOULD RESPOND BY LEADING
NATO, COLLECTIVE EFFORT THAT
WOULD TAKE OUT EVERY FORCE WE
CAN SEE AND IDENTIFY ON THE
BATTLEFIELD IN UKRAINE.
ALSO IN CRIMEA AND EVERY SHIP IN
THE BLACK SCENE FLEET.
>> Sandra: HOW SERIOUSLY
SHOULD WE BE TAKING THESE
NUCLEAR THREATS?
>> Jesse: I DON'T TAKE THEM
SERIOUSLY.
HE'S NOT AN IDIOT.
THAT WOULD DESTROY ANY SENSE OF
HIS COUNTRY AND HIS FUTURE.
HE WOULD PROBABLY DIE IN A
BLOODY COOL BECAUSE WE WOULD
DESTROY EVERY TARGET IN UKRAINE
AND TAKE OUT, AS PETRAEUS SAID,
THE FLEET AND EVERYTHING IN
CRIMEA.
WHAT I WORRY ABOUT IS JOE BIDEN.
IS HE LISTENING TO SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE AUSTEN WHO I DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT HE THINKS ABOUT
ANYTHING.
I KNOW HE THINKS WHITE SUPREMACY
IS OUR BIGGEST THREAT.
EASY LISTENING TO OTHER HAWKISH
ADVISORS THAT WANT MORE THAN
ANYTHING TO WIN THEIR NEW
COLD WAR AGAINST THE RUSSIANS
BECAUSE IT AN AGGRESSIVE AND SO
SOFT ON FOREIGN POLICY OR IS HE
LISTENING TO RANK AMATEURS LIKE
RON KLEIN?
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A LITTLE
FINESSE.
WE HAVE TO MANAGE THE RUSSIAN
DECLINE.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE HAVE GIVEN THEM
ENOUGH MILITARY, ABILITY TO
REALLY EVENTUALLY ROUTE THE
RUSSIANS IN THE EAST.
HOW DO PUTIN SAVE FACE?
YOU'RE GOING TO BACK THE GUY
INTO A CORNER.
I DON'T THINK HE IS GOING TO
LAUNCH A TACTICAL NUKE BUT HE'S
GOING TO DO SOMETHING.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MANAGE THIS APPROPRIATELY.
I DON'T KNOW IF JOE BIDEN IS UP
FOR THAT.
>> Sandra: WHEN IT COMES TO
THAT RECENTLY ILLEGALLY ANNEXED
AREAS BY VLADIMIR PUTIN IN
UKRAINE, SHOULDN'T WE BE DOING
MORE TO HOLD PUTIN ACCOUNTABLE?
>> Katie: WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
SANCTIONING.
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF TOUGH TALK.
WHAT YOU KEEP HEARING IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU HEARD BEFORE
THE INVASION WHICH IS IF PUTIN
DOES X, THE UNITED STATES WILL
RESPOND IN SOME WAY.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN FOLLOWING WHAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN WANTED TO DO.
THERE HASN'T BEEN A LOT OF
DETERRENCE ON THE FRONT END OF
THAT WHEN I HEAR PEOPLE LIKE
GENERAL PETRAEUS' TIME, WE WOULD
DO IF PUTIN WERE TO USE A
NUCLEAR WEAPON HE IS SAYING
THAT THE UNITED STATES IS GOING
TO BE DRAWN INTO A FULL-SCALE
WAR AGAINST RUSSIA.
IF HE IS SAYING YOU'RE GOING TO
SINK THEIR SHIPS, GET RID OF
THEIR FLEET, TARGET EVERY SINGLE
MILITARY INSTALLATION IN THE
COUNTRY IN RUSSIA AND UKRAINE,
THAT'S THE UNITED STATES BEING
INVOLVED IN WORLD WAR III.
AND I'M JUST GIVING UKRAINIANS
WEAPONS.
THE U.S. INTEREST TO AMERICANS
IS TO PREVENT THE UNITED STATES
FROM GETTING INTO A WAR WITH
RUSSIA.
SO THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT MEANS.
IT MAY MEAN UKRAINE HAVING TO
COME TO THE TABLE.
SAYING THE AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
ANNEXED ARE RUSSIANS.
OR IT MAY MEAN CONTINUING THE
WAR IN A LOT OF WAYS BECAUSE
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY'RE WINNING
WINNING AGAINST RUSSIA AS THEY
TRY TO RECRUIT 65-YEAR-OLDS AND
18-YEAR-OLDS.
IN TERMS OF DETERRENCE, THERE
HASN'T BEEN A LOT THEY ARE THE
BEGINNING.
ALL I HEAR IS ESCALATION ABOUT
THE UNITED STATES GETTING
INVOLVED IN WAR THE AMERICANS
HAVEN'T SIGNED UP FOR AND
CONGRESS HASN'T AGREED TO.
>> Sandra: TO THAT POINT, JOHN
KIRBY WAS ASKED ABOUT THIS AND
HE SAID WE HAVE SEEN NOTHING
THAT WOULD MAKE US CHANGE OUR
STRATEGIC DETERRENT POSTURE.
ARE WE DOING ENOUGH TO SEND
VLADIMIR PUTIN A STRONG MESSAGE
OR A STRONGER MESSAGE TO NOT
CONTINUE TO COMMIT THESE
ATROCITIES?
>> Jessica: BESIDES PUTTING
BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND STARTING
A HOT WAR, YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW HOW PEOPLE CAN SAY
JOE BIDEN HASN'T DONE ENOUGH.
THEY WANT US TO SUPPORT THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE WITHOUT SENDING
OUR OWN MEN AND WOMEN OVER THERE
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DONE.
HE'S GIVEN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
HE HAS BEEN THE FACE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF
LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORTING
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
YOU CAN HEAR IT IN THE WAY THAT
ZELENSKYY TALKS ABOUT HIM VERSUS
OTHER LEADERS.
THERE IS NO MORE THAN HE CAN DO
AT THIS POINT AND PROBABLY TO A
LOT OF AMERICANS LOOKING AT THE
DOLLARS THAT HAVE GONE OUT THEY
WOULD SAY IT'S TOO MUCH.
VLADIMIR PUTIN THOUGHT HE WOULD
WIN THIS IN 11 DAYS.
THEN IT MOVED TO A COUPLE
MONTHS.
LAST WEEK HE ILLEGALLY ANNEXED
FOUR PROVINCES.
THEY HAVE ALREADY TAKEN ONE
BACK.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE DOING THE
BEST THEY CAN BECAUSE OF
AMERICAN ASSISTANCE BECAUSE WE
ARE GIVING THEM ALL THE SYSTEMS
THAT THEY NEED TO FIGHT THEIR
WAY OUT OF THIS WITHOUT
SACRIFICING AMERICAN LIVES AND
THAT'S WHAT JOE BIDEN WAS
CHARGED WITH.
>> Jessica: PETRAEUS ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT HE SAW THE
NUMBER OF SETBACKS FOR THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY LATELY.
MIKE POMPEO WAS TALKING TO
MARTHA EARLIER AND SUGGESTED
MAYBE WE ARE AT A TIPPING POINT.
>> Greg: HERE'S THE THING.
THE FOG OF WAR.
EVERY TIME I HEAR SOMETHING THAT
SAYS RUSSIA IS DOWN AND OUT,
ONLY TALKING ABOUT DISTANT
BOUNTY.
I GET THE FEELING BECAUSE THE
DUELING BANJOS OF PROPAGANDA
HAVE GONE AWAY.
MAKES ME THINK THEY ARE IN
TROUBLE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM
WITH THE P WORD.
EVERY TIME YOU BRING UP THE WORD
PEACE, SOMEBODY THINKS YOU'RE
SAYING PUTIN.
THIS IS THE THING THAT IS REALLY
WRONG ABOUT IT.
I HAVE A PROBLEM THAT EVERYBODY
IS PRO-WAR AND IT'S ON THE BACK
BURNER.
WE ARE NOT EVEN REALLY COVERING
IT ANYMORE.
WE ARE POURING THEM ON THE END.
MEANWHILE ELON MUSK TWEETS
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT SEEKING PEACE.
WHO ATTACKS HIM?
ZELENSKYY AND OTHER DIPLOMATS.
YOU CAN'T ATTACK PEOPLE PAYING
FOR YOUR WAR.
I UNDERSTAND.
IT'S YOUR COUNTRY.
YOU ARE INVADED.
LOOK, WE ARE PAYING FOR IT.
WE CAN HAVE AN OPINION.
I DO THINK THAT MY FEAR HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THAT THE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IS EXTENDING THE
DURATION OF THE WAR WITHOUT
CHANGING THE OUTCOME.
WHAT KATIE SAID IS TRUE.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A SOBER ANALYSIS
OF WHAT EXIT RAMP YOU CAN GIVE
TO PUTIN.
EVEN IF IT'S WHAT HE ALREADY
HAD.
TO PRETEND ALL OF US KNEW THE
NAMES OF THESE PLACES TWO WEEKS
AGO, THAT'S PHONY.
THEY ANNEXED THESE PLACES.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THEY
ARE.
WE KNOW MORE ABOUT YOUR OWN
WHICH IS ON.
THERE IS A REVOLUTION GOING ON
IN IRAN AND WE DON'T GIVE A
DAMN.
WE ARE DOI